I believe that I'm the best in the world
she's such a dominant figure is on
another level I haven't seen this kind
of dominance in a long time one of the
great wh ifs in MMA history we all
thought like she's going to be a
champion the former wrestling Prodigy
returns after nearly 4year layoff what's
your
name my entire life people told me that
I shouldn't wrestle because I was a girl
I shouldn't be there cuz I was a girl
come on B shut up she just quack put
these kids to their back Tatiana Suarez
is one of the Pioneers I would say of
female wrestling I was just kind of the
biggest eye opener like wow this is
really something that I could do at one
point a US Olympic hopeful in wrestling
those plans were derailed with a serious
injury which revealed something much
larger than that it ended up being
cancers she kind
of went into in the
dark
over the years you've had a variety of
injuries it's a real travesty you break
your neck you get thyroid cancer then
you blow your entire knee out life is
thrown a lot at her I don't think I've
ever thought about giving up on anything
but I really felt
it I knew that I wasn't done I'm going
to find a way to fight
again the things we asked Tatiana to do
I don't know many athletes who could
have endured it
I was off for a very long time you just
think to yourself like well I be the
same
athlete but this time you would be
cleared to compete she's worked her
whole life to get here and she's
overcome it
all s is The Ultimate Fighter the
journey makes you a better person if you
use the obstacles to make you better I'm
from a place it says we don't break I've
overcome a lot and I'm never going to
stop till I'm at the top
[Applause]
w